[Music]
you ever wake up angry it's weird right
nothing's even happened yet you're like
[ __ ] I don't like where this is headed
it usually happens when you're broke
alright broke people wake up angry
because when you're broke that is the
first thing you remember when you wake
up I tell you think about when you're
broke I'm broke you do your job you do
your errands but all your thinking the
whole time is I'm broke I'm jog and I'm
broke
doing paperwork I'm broke even when
you're having sex I'm broke
thank god this is free I'm not saying
rich people don't get angry they do I'm
just saying it's hard to imagine George
Clooney rolling over in his mansion in
the morning going good what have I done
with my life so I need more money said
that the other night some guy goes money
can't buy you happiness I'd like to do
my own research on that kind of a weirdo
someone's always got to say that though
I don't know is just self-righteous well
then I can't buy you happy money can't
buy you happiness okay but can I be sad
in a nicer apartment
thank you sir
I deserve that yeah that's what I wanted
want to be sad and I have a tiny
apartment hmm
and and you got to walk five flights of
stairs to get to it yeah yes five
flights of stairs to get to a tiny
apartment so it's exhausting then
disappointing it's like taking a really
long hot bus trip to Denny's
my my uncle says I need to work harder
that's the only that's the answer he
says I want you to swear Carter but old
people's favorite thing to talk about
how people younger than them don't work
hard you don't work hard your generation
has no work ethic I worked harder than
you okay I can beat you at Xbox two
things that don't matter I think old
people did work harder than us you know
why cuz there wasn't anything else to do
back then they used to fly kites
it's easy to be a hard worker when the
alternative is checkers but I got real
distractions I got a cell phone I got a
computer I can video games they had
yo-yos you know how bored you have to be
to play with a yo-yo I'd rather work
[Applause]
[Music]
if you hand into killing yo-yo today
he'd hang himself with it yes old people
worked harder but it was a different
country back then it was a manufacturing
country they were building stuff back
then highways and cars and buildings
grandpa had to focus back then if he
didn't focus he fell up the skyscraper
most of us are in cubicles we don't
focus we go onto the internet watch
YouTube Hey look a guy falling off a
skyscraper
[Applause]
you